[Musique]
là
willkommen bienvenue welcome cabaret en
cabaret en cabaret
attends chez toi ta femme elle tu
appelleras soit lisse sans non plus
souvent un appel stupide où elle me dit
et connard tu t'amènes
[Musique]
ça vous gêne le côté paparazzi de
célébrités dont vous avez été quand même
ses victimes en ce moment de plaisir ont
les mêmes je crois
c'est tentant de vous retrouver mais
personnellement oui mes appuis surprise
aussi parce que je m'y attendais pas
vous savez dans un raid en guinée mr sy
ableman ah oui
[Musique]
je
nos colonnes oui
oui mesdames messieurs bonsoir
voici lunettes opus 24 noires pour nuits
blanches concerto en ut majeur pour
platine et sampler auto interview blind
tests et questions pont tous les grands
classiques de l'émission qui connaît
parfaitement
[Musique]
john holmes
de reason why i needed you is because
possible formation
or il pose une colle et comme duplo
qu'on dit maintenant marié veille qui a
coulé le titanic icebergs ont encore un
juif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que t'en fais pas je suis crevé
c'est la première fois que ça me fait sa
demande cette barre je vous dirai ce que
je vois les éléphants roses ça regarde
regarde ça merci il ya deux éléments
aussi voulu plier une cirrhose jean yves
à tous les retraits en espèces château
je préfère to be wild ronald reagan
george bush
gorbatchev au point de vue gamma gt j'ai
battu les records
ouais ouais j'ai battu bohringer de
l'avant table tu étais niveau gainsbourg
qua non il était ridicule ridicule non
mais si tu veux j'ai arrêté comme a fait
james dean vraiment où il fallait ouais
est ce que tu as déjà fait l'amour à
plusieurs à plusieurs femmes à plusieurs
femmes par exemple en même temps oui
j'imagine oui mais vous êtes retrouvée
enceinte est en fait le mariage a eu
lieu la veille de l'accouchement
samedi c'est gratuit c'était juste avant
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un gain
soit juste et légale
fait complaire à des médias bitouah
immédiatement allé à la base
vas-y moi j'ai pas mieux
[Musique]
j'habite de seul avec maman
dans un très vieil appartement
bruce arasa
[Musique]
fumel qui ne leur avait pas de vêtements
de livres de t'expliquer redit son quoi
quelques malades c'est quoi loulou à
j'adore je suis là je suis senti mal
politis des bananiers 3d tecla noble
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord tu as vu ce qui se passe là tous
ont de quoi tu parles de quoi la radio
charles bonheur bonsoir
[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde donne sec soit une
fois c'est une proposition vous avez
déclaré après le tournage du film brad
pitt est un grand du baiser que ç'a très
bien été payée façon quand on dit un
truc pour la première fois on peut
toujours se tourner les ennuis vous avez
vous remarqué là où je vois pas non
un amant peut-être m j'aimerais eh oui
alors messieurs
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
il
à
oh
[Musique]
là
deux hommes m'ont répondu oui allô oui
si vous voulez on peut aller dîner
ailleurs aussi un quatrième contraignent
à lancer et 4e we all à goethe accueil
personnellement c'est johnny moi c'est
lui qui me l'a raconté bassabi t'arriver
donc c'est normal non il va dans un va
dans un supermarché c'est geof qui
pendant les vacances l'a décidé dans un
supermarché ce que vont faire les
courses soit on est en vacances il fait
les courses y poussent le cas dit elle
est ici à côté et tout y pousse le
caddie pousser le caddie
machin est il pour les trucs et tout et
puis il ya les mecs donc supermarché qui
distribue les des débits tombe de
tombola toi comme ça ils l'ont mais un
dans le caddie et tout est ici à le
prendre une petite config est un peu le
ramdam autour c'est johnny qui dans ce
supermarché il entend au micro ou de de
dix minutes elle aux numéros gagnants
évidemment les tice à lui fait johnny
c'est toi tu as ta le numéro moi tu fais
mais je m'en fous je peux y aller mais
si sivadier bélie va tenter un nom mais
il y va il y 20 et le mec d amour disent
surpris de voir johnny tu vois combien
un commun et gagner alors à temps il a
gagné son toit il en faisait d'abord non
médecins il a gagné son poids en
chocolat bon son poids parce que c'est
la promo en noix de coco chocolat noix
de coco et et 150 euros par jour 150
euros par joueur jusqu'à ce qu'il fit
des bounty
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les bras
outre mm
m
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu